yes what's up this is andrew from
chainsenses.com so today is a big day
guys we finally
had the breakout on amc yesterday
at the 4d level so it's going to be very
interesting for me to go
through yesterday's press action with
you guys today see
if this reversal is solid if this
breakout is real
and trustful and see what are the next
potential moves
so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so i'm very excited today
to do this analysis
there are a lot of things i want to show
you a lot of interesting things
i'm going to show you guys all my
different scenarios
i'm going to tell you if yes or not
we're going to come back to the 40
38 42 area you're gonna see i have
quite good examples to show you here and
yeah let's discuss
all this stuff so let's start on the 15
minutes time frame i'm doing
some okay so let's get rid of that let
me remind you as usual guys what i was
saying in my yesterday's analysis about
amc
so basically i posted everything i'm
talking here about guys in my discord
so go and check it out it's still for
free guys for at least one more week i
think
and i'm gonna basically tell you guys
what i
was saying here so my first scenario was
that we go to the 3840 area so yesterday
we were
at 35 so in open in pre-market i posted
a video saying that we don't have any
bullish signs yet
but right after i post that 35 was
broken
which is very good guys it has not been
re-tested it was not a strong
support level resistance than support
and here
the next resistance levels were of
course 38 and 40 so
uh there was for me a 70 chance that we
were going right away to it and that we
would find some rejection at this level
so once again let me remind you how i
find these levels so the 38th level
is here you just look for consolidations
area i guess this is something you can
use on any stock any asset price
anything that is moving
as long as you have those consolidation
you can see here
here then you probably gonna have some
reactions so here 38
has been broken right away in the 15
minutes time frame
then 40 that was my major resistance
level that you can see
40 is here the height that i have in
this last move down
and it's above all most importantly the
breakout level that i had that i have
using this trendline get this move down
i love using trend lines i've been using
them for a very long time
this technique is very very efficient it
gives very good signals
that are followed by a lot of investors
so those signals are very good to use
and here we had
as you can see yes this consolidation
between 40 and 38
and in all this area i guess so here we
we could potentially
make a bullish trend at 38 but then i
would use a stop loss just below yes
because here we could still have been
rejected
but in the last hour of trading guys we
had this brutal
and wide breakout that i like to see
with strong associated volume we i'm
gonna come to the volumes very soon
so how many shares 240 000 shares
both at the close gas at the 4d level
because once again
you can see that here this breakout was
confirmed under 15 minutes time frame so
of course it's not
enough yet to be sure uh this breakout
is not a fake out but when you have the
volumes that strong that confirms the
breakout happened
so now what is the situation what are
our different scenarios i'm gonna come
to this very soon
so basically i was saying in my discord
don't formal between 38
and 40 because usually when this levels
are broken that then
uh re-tested so i'm gonna come to this
right now guys what are the next
resistance levels so once again to find
the resistance levels guys the same
technique
as usual you find the consolidation
areas in the last move down
so here it's pretty obvious you have one
here guys all right at 50
because you can see the most recent the
better so first it's the
recent high that we have here and you
can see that heat has been tested here
it consolidates yes i can zoom in you
can see it very well
you know it's consolidating i'm only 15
minutes time frame so we spent two hours
here
here you can see it has been rejected
not perfectly retested here guys so the
most recent pass is the best to use
so all of this is for me enough and i
think i think i still have some
reactions
as well in the all the past somewhere
here
not very clear but this is more than
enough for me so
i know that 50 is the next resistance
level so what are my different scenarios
so here i'm having to break out the
breakout is happening on the forum frame
it is not confirmed yet on the daily but
i have no doubt it will be confirmed
today
when i'm gonna post this video here we
are going to count
the waves because this is a very good
information that we can get from this
market
so first number one here once again why
here i was not that bullish you can see
that guys here i have three waves
i mean it's pretty easy to count a b
c okay you cannot make five waves out of
this move
here you can make one two
three four five same you can make five
ways so here we were still bearish
what started to be bullish and i gave
you this trend in my discord once again
guys
is when we broke here the trend line and
then retested it so i know that a lot of
you guys
entered amc at this level which is a
beautiful level
much better than buying 31 without stop
loss as we're discussing in my discord
as well
and here so you can see now first wave
correction
then here one two three
four five so the third wave is complete
we are consolidating
so i'm gonna get rid of this one i don't
wanna have too many of those but you can
see the third wave is complete
we are waiting for fourth and a fifth
that would be the
ultimate confirmation that we are moving
up that
motif waves which have five waves
according to
elliott wave theory are going up so i
really want to see five ways i already
have five ways in my third wave so it's
already more than enough
but i would like to see this
confirmation and this amc reached this
new height so here
we're going to have a small
consolidation so once again to know
where the force wave is going to go you
count the waves and we usually go to the
top of the third or the bottom of the
force
to be honest i don't think we're going
to retest 40 right away this move
is you know very sharp at the close so
we might have a very small false wave
correction here and just
move right away higher all right so
usually we go to the top of the third or
bottom of the force so maybe we
we would come to this area before going
to 50
but it's not my preferred scenario i
think the correction is going to be
lighter here so maybe a very quick dip
and then we're gonna move to 15 but then
we are gonna assume which is the kind of
most bullish scenario
here the question i'm trying to answer
is are we gonna have a retest around the
28 40 42 area and i'm gonna give you an
answer guys and the answer is yes we're
gonna have it
and to answer this question i'm gonna
build up with you different scenarios
first we're gonna have a look at the
past so let me go in the 30 minute time
frame
and let's see guys so i want you to
understand
that this situation is different from
you know here
before breakout we took 25 percent all
right this is
an information we're having we didn't
correct here yet we are coming from the
lows guys we're coming from the lows
without a correction in the first wave
here move up
i want to compare this situation to the
situation we had for example here
so i'm gonna analyze with you two
breakouts that we had
the first one is this one
okay so in this situation guys
after this correction i just connect the
highs that are here
you can see that this level has not been
retested almost we tested by the way
you can see i'm just applying the same
method connecting the highs
and having my breakout level you can see
that here we
the breakout occurred at the lowest
level it occurred
at 570. so of course then it's tough to
re-test but even here we almost retested
it
with the low at six and then we only
moved higher and we never retested it
but this situation
is more comparable to this one guys with
this breakout same technique
i connect the highs that i have here on
the log scale guys very important
and here you can see that we are coming
from the lows
same we take 20 okay so very comparable
then what happened let's see guys let's
see then after that we took
another 15 20 and then we retraced
78 of this first wave so i think that
something like this is more likely to
happen because here you can see guys
that we're coming from the lows we took
20 so the breakout level
is not at the lowest point which is you
know a different situation that like for
example if we had to break out here guys
right
if we had the breakout at 33 of course
the breakout level would not be retested
but this is not the case here
so here for me the most likely scenario
is that
we keep going higher we get rejected at
50 we complete our first wave and then
guys
you know how to do it you know how to
enter this kind of threat because i'm
giving you this many
i gave you this many times i'm gonna
keep giving you this you just check the
fibs if you're not
at ease with doing trend lines with
breakouts are you sure it's a breakout
and out here we have the volume so it is
a breakout you just take the fibs and
you know guys that second wave depending
if it's a flat triangle no it cannot be
a triangle
it can be but zigzag are flat
zigzag they usually like to correct you
know do something like this
okay to the 50 or 61.8 retracement level
so if we go to the 50
it's the level is 40 and the 38
the 61.8 percent is 38. so if it's a
zigzag correction after we went to 50 we
would probably go
to the 38 40 area by friday
all right around here okay even maybe
thursday depending
how fast this happens so in my first
scenario we will trace to 38 awfully
i would be actually a buyer of those two
levels
myself here if it's a flat correction
then we would only go to 38.2 percent
you know which is 42 roughly all right
so 42.5
so in the kind of best case scenario
i would say for amc which means that the
correction is
very shallow here even in this situation
we'll go to 42
so i give a 90 chance that we go to 42
by friday
after going to 15 and i give
50 60 probability that we go lower
usually we go lower guys right
especially when we coming from far so
here this would be a total move
of 60 so usually after these strong
moves
everything can happen it's amc guys so
everything can happen just keep this in
mind but my preferred scenario would be
a correction
to the 50 area which is around 40
so i believe 40 will be retested by
friday
and then of course guys this would be
our third wave we are waiting for
so we are doing the first wave of the
fifth right now
then would be the third and you guys
know that this is the most powerful one
usually and the one that is taking the
major level so i expect the third wave
to take the 72 73 level
then correct and go to the target 100
135
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video i hope i managed to
explain the different techniques that i
like to use when i
trade breakouts how to know where the
retest is probably going to happen
when it's going to happen the different
situations we can have on breakouts
coming from the lows or a breakout
that is close to the lows which is
different situations with different
trading techniques that we're gonna use
so if you did enjoy this video
please don't forget guys to click on the
sub like and bell button so you're gonna
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys